u.s. Democratic congresswoman receded -
Lib has rejected an offer from Israel to
allow her to visit a Palestinian
grandmother in the West Bank
she received special permission early
today which reversed a previous Israeli
ban on her entering the territory
Israel's offer came after congresswoman
Talib agreed not to promote boycotts
against the country during her visit the
day before Israel announced that it had
barred her and fellow Muslim
congresswoman Ilhan Ouma over their
support for a boycott campaign against
the Jewish state let's get the laces
from DWR Washington correspondent Pablo
Foley Elias a welcome Pablo so why has
receded talib changed her mind about
going I felt well it looks like she's
made it very clear actually in a series
of tweets that she won't be traveling to
Israel and on to the West Bank in fact
if we actually just see what she said
she said that silencing me and treating
me like a criminal is not what she wants
from me referring to her grandmother it
would kill a piece of me I've decided
that visiting my grandmother under these
oppressive conditions stands against
everything I believe in fighting against
racism oppression and injustice so we
can we can understand from that that the
Michigan congressman won't be travelling
on to Israel and to the West Bank now in
response about the Israeli Interior
Minister in Rea Interior Minister Rea
Derry said at the US Congresswoman
request to visit was a provocation to
embarrass the country after she rejected
Israel's offer to let her to travel to
the occupied West Bank to see family
there on humanitarian grounds now that's
referring back to also the this tweet
and to a letter written on Thursday by
talib where she had requested entry to
the West Bank and Israel so that she
could visit her elderly grandmother now
we also know that the other
congresswoman who was also part of this
ban
Ilhan Omar she remains banned from
traveling to Israel so how is Congress
reacting to israel's treatment israel of
course
supposedly a big ally of the United
States how is Congress reacting to
Israel treating one of their own in this
way well Phil this is an unprecedented
move let's not forget that in fact has
been bipartisan support in Congress
since which is sort of like the the
backbone of the relationship between the
US and Israel since the foundation of
the Israeli state and there's been
particularly from the Democratic Party a
lot of criticism at geared towards
Israel and president Donald Trump over
this decision in fact the House Majority
Leader Steny Hoyer said on Thursday that
it was a grave mistake that undermines
the bipartisan pro-israel consensus
Nancy Pelosi a big supporter of Israel
also came out saying that it was a big
mistake on the part of Israel and
interestingly the pro-israel group AIPAC
which was being very critical of Omar
anta lead in the past had actually said
that it was also a mistake on the part
of Israel and that they should
nonetheless a despite their support for
the boycott of Israel they should
nonetheless be allowed travel to Israel
and then what's also quite and notable
is the silence will say from the
Republican Party and we've heard very
little reaction from that side and but
in fact a president Donald Trump who was
speaking at a rally up in New Hampshire
yesterday didn't really go into the
topic as much as I guess as many people
expected he did mention it he said it
was the right decision on the part of
Israel and and what sort of happened is
that there's a belief here many critics
are saying that the Republican Party are
attempting to say that the Democrats are
divided over their support for Israel by
highlighting and using Talib and Omar as
sort of examples of what the Democratic
Party believes or what their feelings
are towards Israel but in fact we just
have to look back at last month when in
fact the House of Representatives of
course democratic-led voted
overwhelmingly
in favor of a resolution against the the
Israel boycott at movement so at the
moment we're hearing very little like I
said from the Republican Party but the
Democrats are putting a lot of support
behind Omar and Talib Harbor Foley Elias
in Washington thank you